euh donc merci beaucoup d'avoir
euh un peu de temps pour écouter toutes
les mauvaises nouvelles que je vais vous donner
euh en gros ce que euh je vais essayer d'
expliquer
cet après midi en france et donc ce
matin euh donc
aux us euh  c'est une sorte de résumé du
cours que j'enseigne au mintec en
essayant d'expliquer euh pourquoi euh si je le mets
en mots très simples
euh quand on essaie de comprendre le monde à
travers l'économie
euh on rate des points majeurs en fait on risque de
rater
surtout tout le  points euh et pourquoi
euh le genre de fête que nous
célébrons depuis quelques siècles
maintenant va se terminer euh le souhaite ou non euh dans
les décennies à venir et ce que cela signifie pour
nous
c'est fondamentalement ce que je vais faire maintenant tous
ceux  qui sont pressés, vous pouvez partir
donc la question était euh la technologie
nous sauvera-t-elle du
changement climatique donc comme vous le savez probablement
euh un livre vient de sortir il y a
quelques jours qui dit oui alors
euh encore tous ceux qui sont pressés
peuvent  pars en
fait ce n'est pas si simple et je m'en
vais  pour
essayer d'expliquer pourquoi donc on discute du
changement climatique
euh en fait le système climatique euh le
système climatique est une grosse
machine physique euh qui se déroule sur
terre
euh une grosse machine dynamique terminale euh
qui existe depuis les
quatre derniers milliards d'années parce que
euh il y a eu un système climatique sur
terre depuis qu'il y a eu une
atmosphère sur terre
et ça fait quelques milliards d'euros que
le système climatique a toujours changé donc
nous n'avons pas induit de
changement climatique le système climatique a toujours changé
depuis qu'il a
depuis  on avait eu une atmosphère sur terre
mais ces changements peuvent avoir lieu
sur euh des durées euh qui varient beaucoup
selon le forçage qui est la
cause externe ou interne du changement climatique
par exemple euh on a une variation rapide
du climat du changement climatique  pour ainsi
dire
euh qui suit les changements qui se produisent
dans l'atmosphère
et qui font que le système change au
fil des jours
et c'est généralement le genre de changement
que le wea  la
prévision va vous expliquer euh plus froid
ici
plus chaud là etc mais il y a d'autres
causes
de changements du système climatique que
ce qui peut se passer dans l'atmosphère
par exemple ce que vous pouvez voir ici c'est
que sur des
milliards d'années en fait le soleil a
changé
par exemple, il y a quatre milliards d'années, la
puissance du soleil
était de quelques dix pour cent inférieure à la
puissance actuelle
et donc la terre recevait moins d'
énergie que l'énergie qu'elle reçoit aujourd'hui,
ce qui a bien sûr changé le système climatique
sur euh disons euh dix mille
à  cent mille euros les
paramètres orbitaux de la terre désolé je n'ai pas
traduit euh
changent et c'est notamment euh dû au
fait que
euh le système planétaire qui orbite
autour du soleil
ne comporte pas une seule planète qui
est la terre
mais neuf planètes et  euh à savoir deux
planètes massives
euh jupiter et saturne qui euh
exercent une sorte d'attraction en fait pas
une sorte d'attraction sur la terre
et qui provoque les paramètres orbitaux
de la terre à changer avec le temps
changent lentement et c'est par exemple
ce qui a déclenché
les glaciaires de l'ère quaternaire
vous pouvez avoir la dérive des continents qui a
changé le climat par exemple le fait
qu'un continent ait pris place en
antarctique il y a environ 30 millions d'années
lentement refroidi le climat parce que vous
aviez un gros glaçon
qui y est apparu la formation de
montagnes
ou le changement du niveau de la mer est aussi
quelque chose qui peut changer
le système climatique se produit sur de très
longues périodes de temps les
volcans peuvent être une cause de
changement climatique massif  par exemple l'
une des hypothèses euh concurrentes pour
expliquer l'effondrement des dinosaures est des
éruptions volcaniques massives euh qui ont eu lieu
dans les pièges du deccan il y a environ 60 ou
70 millions d'années
alors vous pouvez avoir euh encore des
interactions entre les calottes glaciaires et l'
océan
et l'atmosphère qui peut changer le
système climatique euh
sur cette échelle de temps vous pouvez bien
sûr avoir le changement de l'
effet de serre que je suis  va expliquer dans
quelques minutes ce qui peut
changer le système climatique et l'
effet de serre a changé avant qu'ils ne
soient humains sur terre
parce que la composition de l'
atmosphère a changé parce
qu'avant il y avait des humains sur terre
et enfin et surtout aujourd'hui
et en fait  euh dernier mais les principaux codes
euh sur des échelles de temps courtes c'est le
siècle
euh nous voici encore une fois quand vous
regardez le changement du système climatique
sur le euh je dirais un jour ou
quelques jours vous regardez les prévisions météo
quand  vous regardez euh le changement du
système climatique
sur un siècle à mille ans vous
regardez
je dirais le changement climatique qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui
mais vous pouvez regarder sur des échelles de temps plus longues comme
je l'ai dit euh et c'est le changement entre
euh la glace  des âges euh tu sais
euh quand quand tu as ferraillé euh et euh
des âges chauds présents euh et c'est ce que tu
as appris à l'école
euh qu'il y a eu une oscillation
entre les deux durant l'ère quaternaire
donc  encore une fois, le système climatique a toujours
changé
et ce qui est en jeu aujourd'hui est de
comprendre à quelle vitesse
le climat change à cause de nous
et comment se compare-t-il
au changement climatique passé et si à
cause de cette comparaison
nous courons un gros risque ou non c'est
le  question aujourd'hui donc la question
n'est pas le changement climatique la
réponse est oui ça a toujours été
oui la question est est la principale cause du
changement climatique aujourd'hui ce
sont les activités humaines et où est-il
susceptible de nous amener
c'est la question donc la cause principale  du
changement climatique euh causé par les
êtres humains
est ici c'est une émission de gaz à effet de
serre un gaz à effet de serre est quelque chose
qui existe dans l'atmosphère depuis combien de
temps
depuis aussi longtemps désolé qu'il y a eu une
atmosphère qui est de quelques milliards d'
euros
un gaz à effet de serre  est juste un gaz qui a
la
capacité physique d'absorber l'infrarouge infrarouge à ondes longues
émis par la surface de la terre
qui est la définition d'un gaz à effet de
serre pour
les êtres humains  n'ont pas inventé
les gaz à effet de serre ni ils n'ont été les
premiers à émettre des gaz à effet de serre dans l'
atmosphère
donc il y a eu des gaz à effet de serre ils
ont été désolés des gaz à effet de serre dans l'
atmosphère
depuis encore euh tant qu'il y a eu de l'
eau sur terre car le premier
gaz à effet de serre  dans l'atmosphère il y a
de loin de la vapeur d'eau euh et les activités humaines ne changent pas
euh la teneur en eau de l'
atmosphère pas directement au moins
euh ça change indirectement à cause du
réchauffement climatique mais
pas directement à cause de nos émissions
ici vous avez les émissions de  le
deuxième gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
par ordre d'importance qui est
un dioxyde de carbone et vous pouvez voir ces
émissions
euh enregistrées sur un siècle et demi
dérivées de l'
utilisation de combustibles fossiles euh et des activités agricoles euh
essentiellement euh parce que c'est la principale
source de méthane  qui est aussi un
gaz à effet de serre donc
ces gaz encore une fois ils ont la capacité
d'absorber
euh l'infrarouge émis par l'
oreille  c'est la surface
et cela fait que l'énergie est en quelque sorte
piégée
près de la surface et lorsque vous emprisonnez
plus d'énergie près de la surface,
vous augmentez le contenu énergétique du
système et, entre autres, vous
augmentez sa température moyenne,
donc l'effet de serre l'
effet de serre est quelque chose  cela a été
compris il y a deux siècles
par le physicien français fourier oui
qui a publié dans l'article
scientifique parce que les articles scientifiques datent de quelques
siècles
un article expliquant qu'il
y avait quelque chose dans l'atmosphère
qui augmentait
la température à la surface ou
près de la surface
et  il a appelé ça augmenter l'
effet de serre il y a
environ un siècle et demi deux des
physiciens dont sont encore français mais aussi
un irlandais ont
identifié euh les principaux gaz dans l'
atmosphère qui provoquaient cet effet
vapeur d'eau et dioxyde de carbone et il y a un
siècle
un  le scientifique suédois arrhenius a calculé
qu'il a été le premier à calculer l'ordre
de magnitud  e qui s'ensuivrait un
doublement du co2
dans l'atmosphère l'ordre de grandeur
de l'augmentation de la température
et qui est de 4 à 5 degrés et que le
calcul était assez précis par rapport
à ce que
donnent les modèles modernes quand on leur pose
la même question
alors qu'est-ce que vous  peut voir ici est à nouveau l'
augmentation des émissions
maintenant pour répondre en quelque sorte à la question initiale,
vous pouvez voir que tout au long de cette histoire, cette
histoire d'un siècle et demi,
nous avons fait d'énormes
progrès techniques tout le temps,
par exemple, nous avons commencé à produire de l'
électricité
beaucoup de gens sur terre croient que l'
électricité est propre
eh bien vous voyez nous avons commencé à produire de
l'électricité propre
euh ou de l'électricité qui ne nous fait pas
fumer
quand vous l'utilisez à moins qu'elle ne provoque un incendie
mais
euh sinon euh ce n'est pas euh et vous
voyez que
cela n'a pas empêché les émissions de
monter après
nous avons fabriqué en fait les
américains l'ont fait donc
le premier ordinateur euh en 1945 l'iniac
et comme vous pouvez le voir  n'a pas empêché les
émissions de continuer à augmenter et en fait
ce premier ordinateur
était très inefficace par rapport à l'
ordinateur que j'utilise actuellement
pour montrer ces diapositives euh parce que le
premier ordinateur l'inac absorbait
150 kilowatts alors que mon ordinateur
absorbe aujourd'hui 20 watts  donc l'eniac était très
inefficace
mais l'efficacité des ordinateurs n'a pas
empêché
les émissions de continuer à augmenter ici vous
avez des ordinateurs centraux qui deviennent communs
ici vous avez le World Wide Web qui
apparaît ici vous avez la
révolution numérique qui apparaît et comme vous pouvez le
voir
rien n'a empêché les émissions d'
augmenter alors
euh vous avez une première réponse à la
question la technologie nous sauvera-t-elle du
changement climatique
la réponse est non parce qu'elle ne nous a pas sauvés
dans le passé
comme vous pouvez le voir nous avons eu beaucoup de
progrès technologiques
ma voiture  aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus efficace que
la voiture
dans laquelle j'ai appris à conduire ma
machine à laver aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus efficace
que la machine à laver que j'utilisais un cen  ter
siècle je ne suis pas si vieux euh il y a 50 ans
euh
un demi-siècle disons euh et cetera et
cetera donc
euh quand tu regardes des objets pris un par
un tous sont bien plus efficaces
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne l'étaient
disons un demi-siècle  ou il y a un siècle ou
un siècle et demi
et rien n'empêchait les émissions d'
augmenter, donc l'histoire
doit être un peu plus complexe que de
simplement
trouver des solutions technologiques, sinon nous
aurions maîtrisé le problème
il y a très longtemps
comme je l'ai dit l'un des  la principale hypothèse que l'
on trouve dans l'atmosphère pour provoquer l'
effet de serre est le dioxyde de carbone
il se trouve que le dioxyde de carbone est un
oxyde le dictionnaire est bien est bien
fait les
oxydes ont une propriété chimique
qui est commune à tous les oxydes c'est
qu'ils sont
très  des molécules très stables par exemple l'
hydrogène sur terre
se trouve sous la forme d'un oxyde
qui est de l'eau
et cet oxyde est resté stable pendant
quatre milliards d'années
donc une fois l'hydrogène se trouve sous la forme d'un
oxyde
qui je  s sous forme d'eau rien
n'arrive
à cette eau en gros rien ne se passe
euh
et ça reste comme de l'eau c'est la même
chose pour le dioxyde
de carbone carbone ou j'aurais pu dire ça pour le
fer par exemple
euh puisqu'il y a eu de l'oxygène dans l'
atmosphère
terrestre disons  Il y a 300 à 400 millions d'années,
tout le fer que vous pouviez trouver sur la
croûte
dans la croûte dans la croûte terrestre, désolé,
s'est transformé en oxyde de fer
et aujourd'hui, lorsque vous cherchez du minerai de fer, vous
trouvez de l'oxyde de fer,
vous ne trouvez pas de fer natif
et c'est très  stable sous forme
d'oxyde
c'est la même chose pour le dioxyde
de carbone le dioxyde de carbone est une molécule très stable
et
cela veut dire une chose une fois dans l'air
tant qu'il est au milieu de l'
atmosphère
il n'y a pas de procédé pour éliminer le dioxyde de
carbone
donc  tant qu'il est au milieu de l'
air, il est éternel,
la seule façon d'éliminer le dioxyde
de carbone de l'atmosphère
est de ramener ce dioxyde de carbone en
contact avec la surface
où l'un des deux suivants t  des choses
peuvent arriver à cette molécule,
elle peut être mangée par les plantes d'une manière
qui est la photosynthèse afin que les plantes soient capables,
avec l'aide de l'énergie avec l'aide d'
un photon qui est la
lumière du soleil, de ramener ce dioxyde de carbone
sur terre euh dans les molécules chimiques
vous savez  désolé les molécules organiques et
l'autre façon dont le dioxyde de carbone
peut être ramené,
je dirais à la surface plutôt
sous la surface, c'est quand il se dissout
dans l'océan
et c'est ce que les physiciens ont appelé un
équilibre de pression partielle,
cela signifie que si la
concentration relative de  le co2 dans l'atmosphère
est supérieur à la
concentration relative de co2 dans l'océan
le co2 passe d'un compartiment à l'
autre d'
accord mais cela peut être inversé euh
si un jour on retire le co2 de l'
atmosphère une
partie du co2 qui s'est dissoute dans
l'océan  va réapparaître dans les airs d'
accord parce que c'est un équilibre la
conséquence de ce que j'ai dit
est qu'une fois que nous arrêtons les émissions une fois que nous
commençons donc aujourd'hui nous avons c  a créé un surplus
de dioxyde de carbone dans l'air
bien une fois que nous avons arrêté les émissions un siècle
après que les émissions ont cessé
une petite moitié du surplus de dioxyde de
carbone
que nous avons mis dans l'air sera toujours
là mille ans après que nous avons arrêté les
émissions
environ 30 du surplus que nous avons mis
dans l'air sera toujours là
10 000 ans après que nous ayons arrêté les
émissions
10 à 20 pour cent de ce surplus sera
toujours là
cela signifie une chose cela signifie que l'
état de l'atmosphère
qui  que nous avions en 1800
est perdu pour toujours
et que le système climatique que nous avions
en 1800
est perdu pour toujours c'est ce que cela signifie donc
cela signifie
que vous ne reverrez jamais le
système climatique de l'an 2000
et même le système climatique de l'année
va disparaître et vous ne le reverrez jamais,
donc le changement climatique n'est en fait pas une très
bonne expression,
nous devrions l'appeler dérive climatique, car
un changement n'est pas nécessairement
quelque chose
que je  l'annonce et deux que vous ne maîtrisez pas
euh même le réchauffement climatique n'est pas quelque chose
que je dirais
euh apporte de mauvais sentiments euh
surtout à la fin de l'hiver euh le
réchauffement climatique n'est pas quelque chose qui
vous menace beaucoup
euh et certainement pas au texas  aujourd'hui euh
donc la dérive climatique serait quelque chose de
mieux adapté parce qu'une dérive est
quelque chose que vous ne maîtrisez pas vous
n'avez aucun contrôle sur la dérive
c'est juste quelque chose que vous
subissez et
et je veux dire que vous devez faire avec ça  euh et
ce graphique signifie une chose qui est très
importante à partir de maintenant
nous n'arrêterons pas le changement climatique nous pouvons l'
adoucir
nous pouvons nous y préparer et nous devrions faire les
deux
donc l'atténuation est absolument essentielle
car nous devrions adoucir l'atterrissage
ou adoucir la chute pour  soyons plus précis
mais on ne l'empêchera pas
on n'arrêtera pas c'est quoi la
le mouvement qui a commencé
une des choses qui euh bien sur est
effrayante avec cette
évolution c'est que ça va se faire
dans le temps f  des cadres qui dépassent largement une
vie humaine
euh bien au-delà de quelques vies humaines
et la plupart du temps bien au-delà
des délais auxquels nous sommes
habitués lorsque nous gérons
quoi que ce soit, donc aujourd'hui la stratégie de tout
gouvernement élu
ou la stratégie à long terme de  n'importe quelle société cotée
c'est trois ans euh quand tu es dans de bonnes
conditions
et six mois quand tu es dans de mauvaises
conditions euh
donc c'est beaucoup trop court pour pouvoir
aborder correctement ce problème
et c'est l'une des tragédies
des pros de ce problème
c'est le fait que nous essayons de résoudre un problème à
long terme
avec des solutions à court terme
le marché par exemple le marché libre
est une solution à court terme
cela ne fonctionnera pas pour ce problème cela
ne fonctionnera tout simplement pas
euh les démocraties sont fondamentalement
les systèmes à court terme donc je ne dis pas
qu'ils ne marchent pas parce que j'aime les
démocraties je veux dire avoir une
certaine liberté c'est plutôt sympa
mais ils ont une grosse
faiblesse c'est qu'euh ils nous poussent dans une
direction
où  on s'en fiche  t problèmes à long terme en
raison de cette augmentation des gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère
comme je l'ai dit, vous avez plus d'énergie qui est
piégée près de la surface et donc la
température moyenne de la surface
augmente les
gens se concentrent beaucoup sur la
température moyenne sur terre
mais  en fait vous verrez plus tard que
le désagrément de ce qui se passe en
ce moment
n'est pas principalement dans le changement de température
ça va être ailleurs
alors euh je sais que les médias euh répètent
encore et encore que où est trois
degrés ou quatre degrés mais ça ne marche pas  ne
dis rien à personne euh parce que tu
ne vis pas dans une température moyenne
euh tu vis dans les
conditions environnantes mais tu vis aussi
dans un monde où tu dois manger euh
tu dois te déplacer
tu dois te rapprocher et  en fait c'est
sur ces éléments
que nous connaîtrons également des
conditions défavorables mais j'y reviendrai plus tard
ce que vous pouvez voir ici euh est un
graphique qui vous montre la
température moyenne sur terre euh le zer  o
ici la référence euh c'est la température moyenne
euh que l'on avait dans la dernière partie du
19ème siècle
ce que vous pouvez voir c'est que euh durant la
seconde moitié du 19ème siècle
le climat était à peu près stable puis
durant le 20ème siècle
la température moyenne  a augmenté de 1
degré aujourd'hui 1.1.2
et cette augmentation est déjà suffisante pour
déclencher
des incendies massifs en californie qui
s'assèche
des incendies massifs en australie qui
c'est suffisant pour avoir déclenché l'émigration
de l'afrique du nord
vers l'europe parce que la sécheresse et euh
la nourriture insuffisante euh  déclenche des émeutes
euh ou pire encore il y a eu un
article publié dans les actes de
l'académie nationale des sciences il y
a quelques mois expliquant que
euh
la sécheresse qui a eu lieu dans le
bassin méditerranéen
depuis 2006 qui a un lien avec le changement climatique
est aussi  lié à l'émergence de daech
dans la région
donc vous voyez avec 1,2 degrés vous avez
vous avez déjà des conséquences qui sont
plutôt grosses
euh je dirais magnitude et ce n'est que
le début de l'histoire malheureusement
et à cause de l'énorme inertie du
co2 une fois dans l'atmosphère et à cause
de l'énorme inertie de l'océan
dans la façon dont le système climatique se comporte au
fil des siècles,
peu importe ce que nous allons  émettre en
fait le système climatique
des 20 années à venir c'est
l'évolution du système climatique euh
c'est déjà écrit
donc si on commence à diminuer les émissions à
partir de maintenant et on devrait le faire
malheureusement ça ne va rien changer
dans le sens  le système climatique va
se comporter pour les 20 ans à venir d'
accord qu'une partie de l'histoire est déjà
écrite
et ce que vous pouvez voir aussi sur cette
simulation c'est qu'on va
bien sûr euh passer par le plafond
de 1,5 et même deux degrés
euh quels sont euh je dirais la
limite supérieure qu'il ne faut pas
dépasser dans l'accord de paris on va
aller au delà
malheureusement on va aller au delà et une
promesse politique
comme vous le savez surement  w euh n'engage que ceux
qui y croient
euh donc il y a eu euh à paris la
promesse politique de limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1,5 degrés
cette promesse ne va pas être bonne
et la promesse de maintenir la
température en dessous de deux
degrés ne va pas être  respecté non plus d'accord
ces deux promesses sont
juste fausses d'une certaine manière malheureusement
euh je vais maintenant entrer dans les
conséquences mais une des choses que
vous devez déjà
avoir à l'esprit est qu'il n'y a pas de
relation linéaire entre l'
augmentation de la température et
la  ampleur des conséquences
bien sûr si je prends ton propre corps
et si tu as une augmentation de ta
température interne
d'un degré tu es un peu malade mais
ça ne t'empêche même pas d'
écouter cette conférence
ok euh toi tu te sens  vous vous sentez
mal à l'aise mais ça va si votre
température interne augmente de
cinq degrés vous ne manquez pas cinq
préférences
cinq conférences désolées vous êtes juste mort
alors
euh il n'y a pas de linéaire c'est pas c'est pas
cinq  fois aussi
mauvais qu'un degré d'accord c'est exactement la
même chose avec le système climatique,
il est rempli de phénomènes euh non linéaires
et donc euh une augmentation de quelques degrés
ne va pas être quelques fois
euh je dirais plus défavorable qu'un
augmentation de degré
peut-être cent fois mille fois un
milliard de fois euh
plus
dommageable c'est euh la façon euh l'amérique du nord
euh
est euh peut être décrite aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez les écosystèmes qui
existent si vous ne les nettoyez pas pour mettre
autre chose
euh  les cultures des villes euh ou les mondes du pétrole de schiste
quoi que vous puissiez voir c'est qu'aujourd'hui
euh la partie interne de l'amérique du nord
est plutôt sèche
euh sèche et parfois chaude donc vous n'avez pas
d'écosystèmes florissants
mais toute cette partie de l'amérique du nord
euh peut héberger euh je le ferais  disons
plutôt sympa parce qu'il y a un
écosystème plutôt riche avec beaucoup de forêts
euh et si vous défrichez la forêt avec beaucoup de
belles
cultures c'est l'amérique du nord euh il y a 20 000 ans
euh donc c'est essentiellement
euh 18 000 ans  avant
euh monsieur jésus christ est né
donc euh comme vous pouvez le voir ça ne ressemble pas
euh à ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui euh la première chose
c'est que vous avez une
énorme énorme calotte glaciaire euh sous laquelle
les canadiens sont enterrés euh donc vous
n'avez pas de goudron  les sables
vous n'avez pas de problème avec les sables bitumineux
vous n'avez pas
euh la clé de voûte du pack pétrolier
euh ce qui déclenche un énorme débat car
il n'y a pas de pétrole à envoyer du canada
pas de canada euh et en fait vous
avez la même calotte glaciaire  ou pas la même mais
une autre calotte glaciaire
euh qui existe sur la partie nord de l'
europe
euh et la partie nord de la sibérie
et pour construire ce gros gros glaçon,
vous devez retirer l'eau de l'océan
et comme le fond de l'océan est dans le
C'est au même endroit que le niveau de l'
océan est inférieur de 120 mètres à ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui, vous ne pouvez donc pas manger de chaudrée de club à boston
car boston n'est pas au bord de la mer,
c'est au milieu des collines non non
pas de port et pas de jetée à  va te promener
la nuit
ce que tu peux aussi voir c'est  que la majeure partie
du continent qui n'est pas enterrée
sous la glace
est assez sèche et froide euh ici vous avez le
désert ici vous avez
des prairies sèches où aujourd'hui vous avez des
forêts
euh et vous avez des écosystèmes de type tigre euh ici
euh qui sont aujourd'hui dans la
partie nord  du canada d'
accord donc les écosystèmes ne prospèrent pas
autant
euh et en fait si les êtres humains vivaient à
cette époque
ils ne pourraient pas cultiver comme ils le font
aujourd'hui
dans cette partie du continent
bien euh quand euh l'amérique
est partie de l'état sur la gauche  à l'
état de droite
évidemment cela s'est produit au cours d'un
réchauffement climatique
que le réchauffement climatique est celui qui a eu
lieu avant
le milieu de la dernière période glaciaire et le
début de la période chaude
qui s'est produite il y a 10 000 ans et qui a
permis à l'
homme  des êtres humains pour s'installer
et créer des densités agricoles alors
le mit d'
accord donc vous êtes les descendants
éloignés comme moi
d'un climat stable qui a duré plus de
dix mille ans
et qui nous a permis d'améliorer euh le
w  oui nous vivons
dans des endroits où le climat donc
les conditions environnantes se sont
arrêtées pour changer le réchauffement qui a eu
lieu afin d'amener le continent de
cet état à cet état
n'est qu'un réchauffement de quatre à cinq
degrés en 10 000 ans d'
accord donc vous pouvez voir  combien cela a changé
le continent et en fait exactement la
même chose s'est produite en europe
euh pour ceux d'entre vous qui viennent d'
europe je suis désolé je n'ai pas
euh la carte pour la chine ou ailleurs dans le
monde mais
comme vous pouvez voir la même chose euh  l'europe euh il y a
20 000 ans euh avait un aspect très différent
de ce qu'elle a aujourd'hui et le
réchauffement qui est parti euh de celui qui a fait
passer l'europe de ce stade à ce stade n'est que de cinq degrés sur dix mille euros maintenant avant que je continue sur une chose qui  je peux
dire en
ce moment, c'est qu'un réchauffement de quatre à
cinq degrés en un siècle
va essentiellement apporter la guerre et l'
agitation et le kérosène partout,
c'est essentiellement ce que cela va
apporter, donc un monde
qui se réchauffe de quatre à cinq degrés  es n'est
pas un monde où votre problème majeur
sera d'avoir l'air conditionné pour
ne pas mourir ou suffoquer en été
c'est un monde où vous prospérerez
pour la stabilité car euh
ça va être la guerre et l'agitation
partout où les
démocraties s'effondreront parmi  d'autres
choses
voici le premier graphique euh je suis désolé je
fais toujours une erreur ce n'est pas camila
mora c'est camilo je devrais corriger que
euh je le ferai avant d'envoyer une tranche euh
c'est une carte qui a été publiée dans la
nature il y a quelques années  il y a
euh 2018 je pense 2017 je ne sais pas
euh où euh avec un modèle les gens
ont calculé le nombre de jours euh
dans une année où tu ne peux pas sortir
parce que tu meurs
pourquoi tu ne peux pas sortir et mourir c'est
parce que
tu vis  dans une région où il fait chaud
et humide
et à savoir que vous avez de l'air
saturé d'humidité
et donc lorsque la température est supérieure à la
température de votre peau
qui est d'environ 35 degrés Celsius,
vous ne pouvez pas refroidir votre corps par
transfert de chaleur
car la température  de l'air est
au-dessus de la température de votre peau
et vous ne pouvez pas refroidir votre corps par la
transpiration car l'air est saturé
de vapeur d'eau
et donc vous mourez d'hypothermie
car vous pouvez voir deux à trois milliards de
personnes
deux à trois milliards de personnes vivent dans des
endroits
où  le nombre de jours pendant lesquels
vous ne pourrez pas sortir
sans mourir sera dépassé
disons la moitié des jours dans une année
et parfois c'est toute l'année
bien sûr
cela n'arrivera pas cela n'arrivera pas
dans un monde  où les gens attendent paisiblement
d'être tués, ils se déplaceront
et euh ils se déplaceront vers des endroits
proches
et les gens se battront et ainsi de suite, etc.
l'immigration
ou l'immigration majeure
entre autres choses que euh
la dérive climatique fera, c'est qu'elle
changera euh
le cycle de l'eau euh essentiellement
dans un système climatique qui est beaucoup plus chaud
vous avez beaucoup vous avez plus d'évap  oration
et donc plus de précipitations mais
elles ne seront pas réparties uniformément
ni géographiquement ni euh je dirais
euh autour de l'année euh vous aurez
des événements de précipitations plus intenses mais vous
aurez aussi des
périodes de sécheresse plus longues euh dans un certain nombre d'
endroits
et le résultat  effet euh dans un dans tous
les pays des latitudes moyennes
euh et et euh à savoir les endroits où
vous cultivez des
céréales aujourd'hui est que les sols vont
devenir plus secs
et si les sols deviennent plus secs bien sûr
les cultures ne prospéreront pas comme aujourd'hui
et cela arrivera aussi  à une époque
où tout ce que nous avons utilisé aujourd'hui pour
augmenter
les rendements des tracteurs agricoles et des
engrais
sera également plus difficile à trouver euh à cause
du fait que le pétrole va être
plus difficile à trouver et je vais expliquer
cela plus tard
euh  les drôles de lettres que vous avez
ici
euh représentent en fait euh le
scénario d'émission de gaz à effet de serre
euh c'est l'accord de paris en gros
euh
et c'est euh tant que nous avons du charbon
nous le brûlons
euh que c'est essentiellement l'idée
ici vous avez un graphique qui a été
publié par le ipcc
il y a un an ou un an et demi dans un
rapport spécial
intitulé le changement climatique et la terre et en
fait c'est la barre à droite qui
m'intéresse
le code couleur sur ces barres est que
lorsqu'il est jaune vous avez des
effets isolés et parfois réversibles
et lorsque vous passez dans la couleur violette cela
signifie que vous avez des effets généralisés
et non réversibles
ce que vous pouvez voir c'est que commençant à
2,5 ou 3 degrés  du réchauffement climatique
concernant l'approvisionnement alimentaire et les stabilités
qui déclenchent des émeutes
à 2,5 degrés ils se
généralisent sur terre
donc encore les gens vont manquer de nourriture le
groenland a commencé à fondre euh il a
commencé à fondre parce que la température environnante
est trop souvent trop élevée euh
et comme  tu sais quand la glace passe au dessus de
zéro elle fond
ou la température environnante pour être
plus précis car la glace est toujours
à zéro mais euh
quand la température environnante est au dessus de
zéro ça m  elts
cette fonte euh est vouée à se poursuivre pour
les siècles à venir
et elle va rajouter trois à six
mètres au niveau de l'océan partout
la partie ouest de l'antarctique
ben l'antarctique étant centrée sur le
pôle sud
on peut se demander où est la partie ouest
mais  c'est ici
donc la partie ouest de l'antarctique
qui est une sorte de château de cartes de
glaciers
qui supportent tous le
voisin risque de s'effondrer si le réchauffement
climatique dépasse les deux degrés
ce qu'il va faire alors vous avez
l'élévation du niveau de la mer
plus  la montée en température de la mer
qui
va attaquer d'une certaine manière euh la
la glace euh qui est proche du rivage
car il se trouve que cette partie de l'
antarctique
est sur le socle rocheux qui est à un kilomètre
sous la mer
donc la calotte glaciaire est  suffisamment épais pour que
la glace colle au substrat rocheux parce que
vous avez un kilomètre de glace sous la
mer mais deux kilomètres de glace au-dessus de la
mer
mais le fait que le substrat rocheux soit sous
la mer
cède la place à la mer  en léchant
la glace au fond et en
s'infiltrant entre la glace et le
substratum rocheux
et en provoquant finalement une sorte d'
effondrement de la maison des voitures
ici, vous risquez d'avoir six
mètres supplémentaires
au niveau de l'océan, donc dans quelques
siècles,
vous risquez trois mètres ici  ou plus six
mètres ici
plus la dilatation de l'eau de mer,
il pourrait donc arriver que dans quelques
siècles, la majeure partie de la Floride soit
sous l'eau
et nous avons le doigt sur la gâchette
aujourd'hui, bien sûr, cela prendra
quelques siècles,
mais c'est aujourd'hui que nous  décider si
cela va se produire ou non
aujourd'hui, les
économistes ont étudié le changement climatique
pendant très longtemps en
essayant de déterminer combien cela pourrait
coûter d'endommager le système climatique,
alors peut-être que je vais
décevoir un certain nombre de personnes qui
écoutent  ce
euh parle mais la réponse est que vous ne pouvez pas dire
pourquoi ne pouvez-vous pas dire parce que par convention
en économie
tous les actifs naturels sont gratuits
comme vous le savez peut-être en économie
tout ce que vous comptez est humain la  bor et
les droits de l'homme
rien n'est euh il n'y a rien pour la
nature
par exemple il est essentiel aujourd'hui que
tu aies 20
d'oxygène dans l'air à respirer pour
que tu restes en vie
et pour que tu puisses produire quelque chose
il n'y a pas un seul comptable nulle part
dans le  monde
où vous avez quelque chose pour ces 20
oxygènes
dans l'air mais si vous supprimez les 20
oxygènes dans l'air, tout le monde meurt et
tout le pib
disparaît mais nulle part dans le pib, vous
trouverez le fait que vous avez 20%
d'oxygène
dans l'air vous  vous ne trouverez nulle part
le fait que vous avez un océan
vous ne trouverez nulle part le fait que vous
avez des sols que vous avez des montagnes que
vous avez de la
pluie que vous avez 30 millions d'espèces
c'est inexistant dans le pib
et entre autre le
système climatique  n'est nulle part dans le pib
maintenant si un actif est libre combien
vaut un dommage à cet actif
zéro par convention, il vaut zéro
donc tous les modèles économiques qui tentent d'
évaluer
combien pourraient causer des dommages à t
le système climatique en fait ils sont tous
basés sur un
raisonnement
c'est-à-dire c'est tout ce qu'ils font en fait ce sont
des modèles logiques totaux
dans lesquels vous retrouvez à la fin l'
hypothèse que vous avez mise au
début
donc si vous décidez que ça coûte cher à
à la fin vous constaterez que cela coûte cher
si vous décidez que cela ne coûte rien à
la fin vous constaterez que cela
ne coûte rien
nordhaus par exemple a décidé que cela
pouvait ne pas coûter cher
alors il dit il conclut que cela ne
coûtera pas cher
et il  obtient le prix nobel pour ça euh
mais
euh ouais bon c'est une longue discussion pour
savoir s'il aurait dû y avoir
un prix nobel d'économie mais euh
qui est plus proche des recettes de cuisine que
d'une science
mais euh euh donc ça c'est
moi je dirais  euh euh si vous vous en tenez aux
faits et à la convention
vous ne pouvez tout simplement pas donner un coût au
changement climatique mais j'ai quand même
euh apporté cet article que je
trouve drôle parce qu'il a été écrit
euh par des gens qui sont chercheurs euh à
chica  aller dans la même université
où le marché la théorie des
marchés libres et les avantages des marchés libres
ont émergé donc je trouve ça drôle euh de dire
que ces gens ont découvert
euh mais ça ne vaut pas plus que toute
autre conclusion
ces gens considèrent que  le coût du
changement climatique se
situe entre dix mille et
six cent mille dollars par tonne de
carbone que nous émettons
aujourd'hui l'américain moyen émet six
tonnes de carbone par an
six tonnes de carbone soit euh près de
20 tonnes de co2
ce qui signifie que  l'américain moyen
coûte de
60 000 à 303 millions
six cent mille dollars par an
pour les dommages
que ses émissions causent au
système climatique
d'autres manières chaque année l'
américain moyen cause des dommages pour un coût qui est de 1
à 60 fois
le pib par  habitant aux états-unis donc si vous
croyez en cet article
il n'y a qu'une seule conclusion que nous
devrions tirer
des chiffres que nous avons ici que
nous avons ici
c'est une raison économique solide  g d'arrêter de
produire quoi que ce soit
demain matin car il faut
émettre du co2 pour produire quoi
que ce soit donc ce que dit cet article c'est qu'en
fait quand on croit qu'on
s'enrichit on s'appauvrit
si on veut
contenir le changement climatique je dirais aux
conséquences les plus faibles possibles
ici un graphique qui va
vous donner la règle que nous devrions suivre
ce graphique vous donne en fait une
je dirais une vue simplifiée des
simulations
qui vont de 18 euh ici 90
à 2100 selon
euh la quantité de gaz à effet de serre que
nous émettons  dans
l'atmosphère et euh le rythme désolé la
base à laquelle nous les rencontrons
ce que vous pouvez voir est que tous ces graphiques
suivent fondamentalement
la même ligne ils suivent tous la même
ligne fondamentalement
et cette ligne est une sorte de réponse linéaire
de la quantité accumulée de  co2 qui
sera mis dans l'air entre l'
époque préindustrielle et 2100
c'est une réponse linéaire de ces
émissions accumulées
à l'augmentation moyenne que nous obtiendrons
en d'autres termes yo  vous n'avez qu'à regarder
la quantité globale
de co2 que nous allons mettre dans l'
atmosphère et cela est
dû à la très longue durée de vie d'un
surplus de co2 dans l'atmosphère que j'ai
expliqué
auparavant, il est donc acceptable de raisonner en termes
de budget carbone
juste les émissions globales que nous
mettrons dans l'air
et cela va vous donner l'
augmentation de température
que nous obtiendrons en 2100
par rapport à l'époque préindustrielle
à la fin de 2018 à cause du charbon, du
pétrole, du gaz et de la déforestation qui
réduit et  brûler du
bois pour faire de la place aux cultures
nous l'avions bien admis non seulement les
gens qui m'écoutent
mais l'humanité dans son ensemble avaient émis
plus de
2000 gigatonnes de co2
et donc nous nous sommes déjà engagés à 1,5
degré d'augmentation de température c'est le
graphique qui  je suis ce que j'ai montré
avant quoi que nous fassions parce que euh cette
augmentation de température
est déjà intégrée d'une manière euh dans les
émissions passées
donc euh le 1,5 degré de l'
accord de paris est déjà mort
nous pouvons s  ay que nous allons contenir le
changement climatique les entreprises peuvent se vanter que
microsoft peut se vanter du fait qu'il est
compatible avec la version 1.5
avec
quelque chose qui
n'existera pas euh j'en
profite pour mentionner cette entreprise
euh pour rappeler une chose qui vient d'
être publiée dans le Financial
Times il y a deux semaines il
y a eu une enquête euh réalisée par
euh la stern school of business de new
université de york en
regardant la fraction
des administrateurs de la fortune 100
donc les 100 plus grandes entreprises aux états-unis
les administrateurs des conseils d'administration de ces
entreprises c'est
euh 1 200 personnes environ cette étude a
examiné les références que ces
personnes
avaient plutôt en matière de climat  le changement et l'
énergie
et ils ont constaté qu'un pour cent d'entre eux
avaient des références dans le domaine de l'énergie et du changement climatique
et les journalistes qui  a écrit l'
article a posé la question suivante
que valent l'engagement les
engagements pris par les entreprises
dans lesquelles les dirigeants ignorent fondamentalement
le problème
la réponse est bien sûr ça ne vaut
rien c'est la réponse logique
ça ne vaut rien si on veut
limiter  euh le réchauffement à deux degrés
alors tu vas dans l'autre sens
ça veut dire qu'il faut limiter euh les
émissions à
l'émission cumulée désolé à 3 000
milliards de tonnes de
co2 dont 2250 pour être précis
avaient déjà été émis fin
et  à la fin de 2020, nous sommes probablement
proches
de euh 2 et 350.
nous avons donc encore un budget carbone pour ainsi
dire
de quelques centaines de milliards de tonnes qu'il
faudrait répartir
entre huit à neuf milliards d'humains
pendant huit ans pour les huit années à
venir
et c'est tout ce qu'on a si on
veut limiter
le réchauffement climatique à deux degrés
quand nos ancêtres proches ancêtres
parents grands-parents avaient trois fois
ce budget
pour une population qui  était à peu près
trois fois moins nombreux,
donc en gros, c'est ce que je
vais expliquer plus tard pour aborder le problème du
changement climatique qui
suit un régime énorme
et même si M. Gates est très
optimiste, la
technologie ne suffira pas à
nous empêcher de continuer un  régime
maintenant la bonne chose à savoir c'est qu'on
va quand même faire un régime
même si on ne veut pas car la terre
est système d'affinité et le diamètre de
la terre était de 13
000 kilomètres il y a deux siècle deux
siècles et il est encore de
13 000  kilomètres aujourd'hui et dans deux
siècles
même si elon musk rêve du
contraire ça fera quand même 13 000
kilomètres
ça ne va pas changer si on veut
être sérieux sur le changement climatique
il faut diviser les émissions mondiales par
au moins trois
jusqu'à ce que mes enfants soient  mon âge, donc au moment où
mes enfants auront mon âge
30 ans, les émissions mondiales devraient être
divisées par trois
si vous mettez cela sous la forme d'
intérêts composés,
cela signifie que les émissions mondiales devraient
diminuer de cinq pe  rcent chaque année à partir de
maintenant
pour les 30 années à venir et il se trouve
que cinq pour cent
est à peu près ce que euh les émissions
ont eu eu une diminution de cinq pour cent
en 2020 en raison de kovid,
donc en gros, aborder correctement le problème du
changement climatique
est, je dirais  faire une pause
qui est une covey supplémentaire cette année
c'est ce que cela signifie si nous ne le faisons pas
nous aurons les conséquences néfastes qui
vont s'amplifier
et qui bien sûr empêcheront un jour
les sociétés humaines de se développer
donc la croissance perpétuelle ne va pas  pour
arriver quelle que soit la façon dont vous le prenez
maintenant si nous devons diviser les émissions pour
i3 où devons-nous agir
ici vous avez un graphique circulaire des émissions mondiales pour
la dernière fois non pas l'année dernière mais en
en 2019. environ 20
des émissions mondiales viennent  des
centrales au charbon seules
appellent les centrales électriques seules appelées nos
usines en fait
euh utilisent du charbon pour créer de la chaleur à partir de cette
chaleur vous créez de la vapeur d'eau sous
pression
et qui est utilisée pour mettre une turbine en
mouvement
et suivre cette turbine  un alternateur
qui génère de l'électricité
vous pouvez générer de la chaleur bien sûr avec du gaz
et vous pouvez générer de la chaleur avec des réactions nucléaires
tout cela est le même principe vous
générez de la chaleur et ensuite
vous créez de l'électricité co des centrales électriques
seules
euh donc elles génèrent 20
des émissions mondiales alors vous  ont des
centrales électriques au gaz
et des centrales électriques au mazout, mais principalement des
qui créent sept pour cent euh des
émissions mondiales, tous les gaz inclus euh
dans ce graphique circulaire
comprenaient le méthane, l'oxyde nitreux et les carbones halo,
tous les gaz sont inclus, donc
la production d'électricité à partir de combustibles fossiles
est responsable
de plus d'un quart des
gaz à effet de serre
et bien sûr ici vous avez le débat
sur la question de savoir si nous devrions remplacer cela par le
nucléaire par les énergies renouvelables d'abord les énergies renouvelables
puis le nucléaire d'abord le nucléaire puis les
énergies renouvelables et cetera c'est le
débat qui se déroule ici
sept  plus sept pour cent des
émissions mondiales euh est sept production
la production de saumon consiste à  casser
la molécule de ligne en deux
et l'une des deux parties est du co2 qui
va dans l'air et pour casser
cette molécule en deux, vous avez besoin d'énormes
quantités de chaleur
qui sont générées avec du charbon ou du gaz
qui crée également des émissions de co2
10 pour cent de  les émissions euh sont
causées par le reste des processus industriels
et ce sont essentiellement les hauts fourneaux
dans la
fabrication de l'acier qui représentent quatre pour cent
des émissions des
chaudières dans les industries chimiques euh
et dans d'
autres matériaux et métaux non ferreux
euh et puis je dirais  euh le
travail mécanique est beaucoup moins intensif euh en deux
émissions
donc quand vous voulez transformer l'acier en une
vis
qui nécessite beaucoup moins d'énergie et émet
beaucoup moins que la fabrication
ou la création de l'acier à partir de minerai de fer
en premier lieu
cinq pour cent des émissions mondiales viennent
des chaudières des immeubles
euh les oeufs de bill ne sont pas chauffés partout
dans le monde
euh par exemple si tu habites à san diego
tu ne chauffes pas beaucoup
euh et si tu li  ve à singapour vous
ne chauffez pas beaucoup non plus
quatorze pour cent des transports euh de euh les
émissions mondiales sont le transport
euh six pour cent proviennent des voitures quatre
pour cent des camions
deux pour cent des bateaux et deux pour cent
des avions avant kavid
maintenant c'est moins euh et donc vous  voyez par
exemple que les centrales au charbon
représentent à elles seules un problème plus important euh
cette voiture bien sûr nous devrions nous occuper des
voitures surtout aux états-unis où elles
sont beaucoup trop lourdes
mais nous avons quand même euh
ici un problème qui est
un peu plus faible que malgré
la tranche je dirais de la pizza 20
des émissions proviennent des processus agricoles
ici vous avez du méthane qui est émis
par le bétail vous avez 1,5 milliard de vaches sur
terre qui
mangent moins de viande est bien sûr quelque chose
qui est utile euh
pour réduire les émissions vous avez du méthane qui
arrive  des rizières
et vous avez du protoxyde d'azote provenant des
champs suite aux
engrais nous suivons le
l'utilisation des engrais 11
provient de la déforestation déforestation  ation
est quelque chose qui a lieu dans tous les
pays où vous défrichez des
forêts pour euh faire pousser des cultures euh
donc ça se passe aujourd'hui avec le soja ça
se passe aujourd'hui avec l'huile de palme ça se passe
aujourd'hui
euh avec euh je dirais partout euh la
population augmente
et les pays occidentaux importent
la déforestation à
chaque fois qu'ils importent des cultures qui viennent
de ces pays
et puis vous avez d'autres processus
comme par exemple la gestion des déchets vous avez du
méthane qui vient des décharges
vous avez aussi des gaz spéciaux des holocarbures
qui viennent des chaînes du froid etc donc vous
voyez les
émissions venir d'un peu  un peu
partout et
encore si on veut être sérieux sur le
changement climatique on devrait diviser ça
par trois dans les 30 ans à venir
maintenant la technologie est plus ou moins utile
selon
euh où on regarde si on veut remplacer
les centrales à charbon par des centrales nucléaires
en effet, la technologie peut jouer un rôle énorme
si vous voulez supprimer les 20%
ici, ce n'est pas une question de technologie que les
gens doivent moins
devons manger moins de viande et nous devons essayer
d'avoir une population mondiale qui n'augmente pas
trop vite
qui n'a pas grand-chose à voir avec la
technologie ce sont les équipes culturelles la
technologie est là c'est un mélange de
technologie et je dirais la biologie comme nous
ce sont des animaux
qu'on aime sortir de chez nous et qu'on
aime sortir de nos bureaux parce qu'un
endroit dont tu ne peux pas sortir
euh toute la journée s'appelle une prison et
tu n'aimes pas ça
euh et ça arrive aussi longtemps  comme
on tient des statistiques en france par
exemple les
gens se déplacent trois fois par
jour depuis 60 ans euh et c'est le
mode qu'ils utilisent qui peut changer
donc par exemple euh la technologie ne changera pas
le fait que nous sommes des animaux qui
veulent se faire  sortir de la grotte et que
nous voulons nous déplacer, mais la technologie
peut jouer un rôle dans la fabrication de voitures plus efficaces
, mais la technologie
ne joue aucun rôle dans le fait que
vous pouvez préférer faire du vélo
plutôt qu'utiliser une voiture, vous voyez donc que la technologie
peut jouer  un rôle mais ça ne va pas  g pour
occuper tout l'espace
ce n'est pas vrai et je vais
conclure cet exposé avec une petite
règle de trois montrant qu'il n'est tout simplement
pas possible que les
deux tiers des émissions proviennent de l'
énergie donc maintenant je dois parler un
peu d'
énergie  donc euh fondamentalement, cela vient de l'
oxydation du carbone
qui est euh je dirais euh
la manière sophistiquée que nous appelons la
combustion
euh et donc cela brûle du pétrole et du
gaz de charbon
euh qui cause les deux tiers des
émissions alors pourquoi faisons-nous cela
pourquoi faisons-nous  utiliser de l'énergie, je suis sûr que si
vous sortez dans la rue
et demandez aux premières personnes que vous
rencontrez ce qu'est l'énergie,
vous obtiendrez tout sauf la bonne
réponse, l'
une des réponses que vous pourriez obtenir est
et
surtout au Texas aujourd'hui est  une
énergie est attrayante c'est quelque chose que
vous devez payer euh
et euh ça peut beaucoup augmenter euh
dans les mauvais moments en fait cette réponse est une
mauvaise réponse c'est toujours une mauvaise réponse
c'est une mauvaise réponse parce que quand vous
regardez ce que l'énergie coûte
à l'être humain  ngs par rapport à tout ce
qu'ils gagnent,
vous vous rendrez compte et arriverez à la
conclusion que cela coûte quelques
pour cent
de ce que nous gagnons en fait, le
prix accumulé sur terre pour acheter du charbon, acheter du gaz
et acheter du pétrole
représente cinq pour cent du PIB mondial, donc
c'est  une petite facture et si vous considérez l'
énergie comme une facture,
vous allez consacrer à l'énergie une
petite fraction de votre temps parce que si
c'est un petit coût,
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous en soucier beaucoup
et en fait
si l'énergie n'était pas cinq  pour cent du
coût mais 99
du coût euh je peux parier que les
références en énergie des administrateurs que
je viens de mentionner ne
seraient pas euh il n'y aurait pas un
pour cent
des administrateurs avec des références en
matière d'énergie mais 99
des références des administrateurs en matière
l'énergie donc le fait qu'il n'y ait
qu'un pourcent c'est justement à cause de ça
c'est parce que quand on dirige une entreprise
on s'en fiche de quelque chose qui ne
coûte pas cher
si je regarde par exemple l'opérateur du commerce
en france sncf
w  qui est le premier consommateur d'
électricité du pays
consomme 1,5% de l'électricité
produite en france et c'est l'un
des premiers consommateurs de nos
produits euh
car nous avons des commerces qui sont alimentés
au gasoil l'
énergie ne coûte à la sncf que 3%
de  ses gains trois pour cent
rien je veux dire les syndicats
c'est une grosse masse euh pour les profits de la
sncf
que le coût de l'énergie d'accord
mais en fait ce raisonnement est aussi solide
que si je disais d'accord ton cerveau ne fait que deux
pour cent de ton poids
donc euh  vous devriez vous soucier de votre cerveau
deux pour cent du temps par exemple
c'est qu'il est assez loin en fait euh
bien sûr votre cerveau représente deux pour cent de votre
poids mais 100 de votre corps
dépend du fait que votre cerveau est
en bon état en
fait c'est pareil  chose pour l'énergie
pourrait nous coûter cinq pour cent de ce que nous
gagnons, mais cent pour cent de ce que nous
gagnons dépend du fait qu'il y a de l'
énergie à cent pour cent,
donc ce n'est pas une bonne réponse la seconde
une  swer euh que vous pourriez obtenir aujourd'hui
euh surtout en europe est l'énergie est
quelque chose à économiser euh en
fait l'énergie n'est rien euh qu'il
n'a jamais été dit
ici vous avez la consommation d'énergie ou
l'énergie utilisée parce qu'en fait
la consommation d'énergie n'est pas un terme approprié
parce que  vous ne consommez pas d'énergie par
vous-même vous ne buvez pas de pétrole et vous
ne mangez pas de charbon et vous ne respirez pas de gaz
et vous ne mettez pas vos doigts dans la
prise je fortement euh
ne vous conseille pas de le faire euh  donc en
fait vous n'utilisez pas d'énergie je
dirai plus tard ce qui consomme essentiellement de l'
énergie mais l'énergie utilisée sur terre
n'a jamais cessé d'augmenter donc il n'y
a jamais eu quelque chose
comme des économies euh à grande échelle
donc pas d'économies euh
quelque chose d'autre que vous pourriez  dites aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que l'énergie c'est quelque chose qui
va être à cent pour cent renouvelable
j'ai de bonnes nouvelles pour vous cent
pour cent renouvelable n'est
pas grave nous l'avons fait pour tous
les temps historiques
avant euh il y a 200 ans depuis l'
ap  parition de l'humain des êtres humains sur
terre
jusqu'à il y a 2000 ans le monde a
toujours été à 100 renouvelable
toujours sur cette photo vous pouvez voir par
exemple
un bateau renouvelable en bois renouvelable
avec une personne renouvelable poussant un
bâton
renouvelable afin de mettre un mouvement renouvelable  en
place sur une rivière renouvelable,
vous avez de l'air renouvelable qui pourrait alimenter
quelque part un moulin à vent renouvelable et vous
pourriez avoir en
aval un repas d'eau renouvelable euh et
vous avez ici du bois renouvelable
qui va donner de l'énergie renouvelable
dans ce château et vous avez un cheval renouvelable
qui  cela permet d'avoir
un transport terrestre renouvelable en
mangeant de l'herbe renouvelable tout cela est
renouvelable d'
accord, donc avoir un monde à 100 renouvelables
n'est pas grave pas grave c'est
faisable
cela a été fait depuis toujours
maintenant la bonne question est pourquoi
comment se fait-il que nous ayons  maîtrisait
depuis si longtemps les énergies renouvelables
comment se fait-il qu'il ait fallu attendre cela
pour construire une civilisation industrielle
s'il était si facile de conserver l'i  n
civilisation
industrielle avec seulement ça comment se fait-il que la civilisation industrielle
n'ait pas émergé alors qu'on n'avait que ça
comment se fait-il que c'est une des questions
que j'ai posée à mes étudiants
euh pour l'examen de fin d'études
que je leur donne
à la fin de mon cours d'accord  l'une des
questions
s'il vous plaît expliquez pourquoi nous avons dû attendre que
les combustibles
fossiles déclenchent une civilisation industrielle
et en fait la réponse
est physique si vous
mettez mille mètres cubes d'air à travers
ce moulin à vent,
vous obtiendrez le même
contenu énergétique que lorsque vous  obtenez trois
millilitres d'huile de celui-ci
afin que vous puissiez le transporter partout où
vous pouvez l'utiliser quand vous le souhaitez
quand ici vous devez attendre que le vent
souffle pour avoir de la farine dans votre
moulin à vent et vous pouvez stocker de la farine
donc avec de la farine vous pouvez  faites-le avec de l'
électricité que vous ne pouvez pas stocker
car l'électricité est par définition un
électron en mouvement
et vous ne pouvez pas stocker un électron en
mouvement à moins
euh en supraconducteur euh mec  rial mais
sinon vous ne pouvez pas
donc euh nous devons attendre cela parce que
fondamentalement la densité d'énergie de ceci
est bien supérieure à la densité d'énergie
de cela et cela fait toute la différence,
donc la mauvaise nouvelle est que vous ne
maintiendrez jamais une civilisation industrielle en
arrière  à cela,
ce n'est tout simplement pas possible ce n'est tout simplement pas
possible
donc euh ce sont de mauvaises réponses et en
fait la bonne réponse
je ne vais pas vous donner la
réponse physique c'est la bonne réponse l'
énergie est iron man pour de vrai c'est ce
que c'est
parce que l'énergie est la nourriture qui peut
alimenter
toutes les machines que sont le
doigt gauche le bras droit le coude gauche
le bras droit le pied gauche et le
genou droit d'iron
man c'est le doigt gauche d'iron man il
peut
tirer des tonnes de
charge qui  vous ne pourriez pas tirer
avec des êtres humains à
moins de mettre des centaines de milliers d'
entre eux pour faire le même travail
ici vous avez des machines qui sont le
pied gauche de fer et qui sont capables de tricoter
beaucoup plus vite cette machine remplace  es des
centaines ou des milliers de
personnes qui auraient besoin de
machines à vêtements construisent eux-mêmes des voitures en
acier
qui ont été fabriquées dans la
bouche d'un fourgon de fer disons et que vous ne pourriez pas
fabriquer avec des bras et des jambes
ce camion est aussi puissant que 4 000 paires
de  jambes
ce repas de bouvillon est aussi puissant est-ce une
aciérie ici
ou un repas de verre tout ce qui est aussi puissant que
10 millions de paires de
bras 10 millions de paires de bras ce
satellite
voit beaucoup plus loin que vos yeux etc donc l'
énergie est la nourriture qui est capable d'alimenter
toute cette flotte de machines la machine
qui nous entoure partout et qui
nous a transformé
en iron man pour de vrai seulement toi tu
n'as pas de costume que tu mets
le matin
tu sais ça donne un coup de pied mais
juste le fait de  manger du pain et du
beurre le matin
a mis en marche cette machine
cette machine cette machine parce que euh
tu as peut être un miroir euh pour laver ton
voleur après avoir pris ton
petit déjeuner
euh cette machine parce que tu  dû construire
toutes les usines
dans lesquelles le pain était transformé et les
récoltes étaient transformées, etc.
vous avez utilisé toutes ces machines et vous ne vous en
rendez pas compte
simplement en mettant du pain sur du beurre le
matin vous les avez
toutes utilisées toutes d'accord
si  vous avez regardé la puissance combinée de
toutes les machines que nous avons aujourd'hui sur
terre
donc à l'heure où je vous parle en ce
moment nous avons toutes ces machines qui
travaillent pour nous
partout sur terre et ces machines
avec leur nourriture spéciale
qui est  pétrole gaz et charbon et marginalement
le reste nucléaire hydroélectricité etc
ils ont multiplié la puissance musculaire
de l'humanité par un facteur 200 en moyenne mondiale
et 600 pour une moyenne européenne et 1 000
pour une moyenne américaine
donc votre niveau de vie aujourd'hui je suis
désolé de  dire
c'est comme si vous aviez 1 000 esclaves à
votre service
toute l'année toute la journée
c'est comme ça si on n'avait pas d'
énergie sur terre aujourd'hui
et donc pas de machines le
pib mondial
serait divisé  d par un facteur 50 à 100
le pib mondial serait divisé par un
facteur 50 à 100
car aujourd'hui la production ne vient pas
des êtres humains elle vient des
machines
et c'est pourquoi tous les modèles économiques
ne tiennent pas compte de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
n'incluez pas l'énergie et les machines ils
croient toujours que le premier
facteur limitant de la production est les êtres humains
non-sens vous avez un excès d'êtres humains
partout vous avez du chômage
partout
donc ce n'est pas un facteur limitant si c'est en
excès
donc c'est pourquoi les modèles économiques échouent
parce que  ils ne collent pas à la
réalité physique
que la production se fait aujourd'hui par des
machines et ces machines ils consomment de l'
énergie c'est leur nourriture
et la conséquence la
conséquence logique de ce que je viens de faire et donc vous
ne consommez pas d'énergie
les machines consomment de l'énergie et quand  tu
dis que tu consommes de l'énergie en
fait euh tu dois enlever cette
expression
te la sortir de la tête et la remplacer
par
maitre ou parc de machines donc par contre  uming
energy c'est maitriser un parc de machines
c'est ça c'est devenir ironman
et là vous avez une relation linéaire
qui est une conséquence logique de ce que je
viens de dire entre
la consommation d'énergie qui est la taille du
parc de machines
de machines actives donc c'est  la taille de
votre costume d'ironman
et ici vous avez le pib en
milliards de
dollars constants donc la macroéconomie
est aussi simple qu'une ligne droite aussi
simple qu'une ligne droite j'ai découvert cette
relation
par chance un jour disons il y a 12 ou 30
ans je  a décidé de tracer
le pib par rapport à la consommation d'énergie
pour voir ce que cela pourrait être
et j'ai trouvé que cela et année après
année
continue et quand vous regardez certains
pays spécifiques dans lesquels le
pib dribble aujourd'hui vous  constatez que ces
pays sont soumis à un stress énergétique
comme la grèce, l'italie, l'espagne, etc.,
donc ce que ce graphique vous dit, c'est que
l'efficacité énergétique
a été active mais à un espace très lent
parce que, fondamentalement, l'efficacité énergétique  y
rend cette courbe un peu convexe d'
accord ça rend cette courbe un peu convexe
mais
c'est un peu convexe vous n'avez
rien qui ressemble au couplage sur
cette courbe
découplage absolu découplage absolu
serait
la courbe qui va comme ça
[Musique]
nous avons  J'ai essayé très fort pendant quelques
décennies et ça
n'arrive pas euh et ça n'arrivera pas pour des raisons physiques
et c'est la situation difficile du
changement climatique parce que la plupart de cette énergie est
des combustibles fossiles
parce que la plupart de cette énergie est des
combustibles fossiles et parce qu'en fait
la révolution industrielle  se débarrasser des
énergies renouvelables est d'arriver à les
remplacer par des combustibles fossiles
ici vous voyez qu'en gros le
pib mondial suit les émissions mondiales donc
c'est ce que je viens de dire avant
vous ne reviendrez pas sur ce point
concernant les émissions alors que le pib
reste même  constant
cela n'arrivera pas cela n'arrivera pas et la
raison pour laquelle cela pourrait surprendre
un certain nombre d'entre vous est simplement parce que le pib
aujourd'hui
est  sans tenir compte des ressources naturelles
et de notre dépendance à l'environnement,
c'est justement la raison pour laquelle la
macroéconomie est fausse
du début à la
fin, vous pouvez donc créer un prix nobel pour une
science complète, vous pouvez le faire,
vous pouvez établir une littérature évaluée par des pairs
pour  une science complète
qui est faite euh mais au fond euh
ouais je veux dire c'est très évident et
euh quand tu regardes le pétrole et le pib euh je
dirais
euh qu'ils sont juste encore meilleurs
ici tu as une courbe une courbe rouge même
chose j'ai découvert ça  par merlok
mais ensuite j'ai trouvé l'explication euh la
courbe rouge
est le changement d'une année sur l'autre en fait c'est
une moyenne mobile sur trois ans mais euh l'
année sur votre changement de production de pétrole
dans le monde c'est la production de pétrole
donc toute la consommation parce que vous
avez  des stocks très limités euh
à la surface de la terre et la
courbe bleue est l'année de votre variation du
pib mondial par rapport au pib moyen par
habitant dans le monde
ce que vous pouvez voir, c'est que les deux s'ajustent très
bien après  les chocs pétroliers
donc après la période où on s'est
débarrassé de
toutes les économies faciles qu'on pouvait faire
et maintenant vous voyez aussi quelque chose qui
est très intéressant c'est que vous
avez un petit décalage
entre la variation de la production de pétrole
et du pib  par habitant et ce décalage
est dans la façon dont le premier pétrole change puis le
pib par habitant
change donc ce n'est pas que nous devenons plus riches
parce que le pib vient de mars
c'est peut-être parce que le pib vient de la masse
que mr musc veut aller sur mars
veut trouver la source  du pib ou de
la source de croissance plutôt
non ce n'est pas parce que vous avez une croissance du pib
venant de la masse qu'on s'enrichit et qu'on
achète plus de pétrole
c'est parce qu'on a plus d'énergie
donc un plus gros parc de machines
qu'on produit plus et qu'on a un pib plus gros en
fait  compter le pib compter l'
énergie en kilowattheures ou compter le
pib
en dollars revient essentiellement à compter la
même chose avec deux unités différentes,
c'est essentiellement ce que c'est,
donc euh le parti dans lequel nous sommes  en ce moment
euh peut être résumé en une seule diapositive nous
avons des combustibles fossiles sous le sol
qui sont gratuits parce que la formation de
combustibles fossiles est gratuite pour tout le monde
vous n'avez pas payé un seul centime pour que tout
existe d'
accord euh gr à dallas euh l'a fait  gagner beaucoup
d'argent avec le pétrole mais il n'a pas créé de
pétrole il a juste eu la
chance de s'asseoir sur le pétrole et de décider
que c'était le sien
mais il n'a pas créé de pétrole la création de
pétrole est gratuite tout
comme la création de vent donc  quand les
gens disent que le vent est gratuit, nous devrions donc
profiter du vent libre
oui mais le pétrole est gratuit parce que la
formation de pétrole est également gratuite
euh donc nous devrions profiter du
pétrole gratuit, c'est ce que nous avons fait,
donc le pétrole est aussi frais que le gaz ils brûlent donc
ils peuvent euh nous permettre d'alimenter des machines
et ces machines vont nous permettre
de transformer tout le reste qu'on trouve
sur terre
des baleines euh aux pierres euh et
elles nous permettent de produire des objets et en
fait ces objets
ne sont que des ressources naturelles qui se
transforment  par machines
c'est ce que ce sont des ressources naturelles
transformées par les machines à
cause de la formidable productivité
du travail qui s'est
ajoutée à nos bras et nos jambes quand on dit
que la productivité du travail
augmente ce n'est pas parce que comme shiva
nous avons maintenant 42 paires de bras et 53
paires  de jambes,
c'est parce que nous avons un exosquelette
de machines qui fabriquent pour nous
et la productivité lorsque la productivité
du travail augmente, cela signifie simplement que vous
avez plus de machines par personne,
cela signifie simplement cela et à cause de l'
augmentation de l'effort de productivité, nous avons
plus de temps libre parce que les machines  travailler pour
nous
et que le temps libre a été consacré à la
création d'
emplois de services que vous n'avez pas dans le monde
de l'énergie rare dans un monde d'
énergie rare les gens
sont occupés euh à cultiver des pommes de terre et à chasser les
animaux
euh ils ne deviennent pas des consultants comme moi
ou  professeurs ou quoi que ce soit nous avons beaucoup
de loisirs
nous pouvons partir en vacances euh
partir euh le week-end arrêter de travailler
après avoir travaillé 40 h  les nôtres dans la
semaine euh on peut prendre sa retraite
on peut poursuivre de longues études avant de
travailler et cetera tout cela
est permis par les machines donc si tu peux
si tu peux faire un doctorat c'est grâce aux
machines
sinon tu ne pourrais pas et je ne pourrais pas faire
mon  travail
euh à cause des machines les gens n'ont
plus besoin d'être à la campagne
parce que les machines travaillent pour nous à la
campagne donc les gens peuvent se rassembler dans les
villes
vous pouvez regarder dans le monde les villes grandissent dans les
pays qui augmentent leur
consommation d'énergie donc leur parc de
machines
vous  n'ont pas de grandes villes euh ou grandes
je dirais euh des villes riches euh dans
lesquelles les gens ont des choses à faire euh et ne
vivent pas seulement dans des bidonvilles
qui nécessitent beaucoup d'énergie et
beaucoup de machines quand la chine a
accédé à l'énergie urbaine
l'immigration a commencé euh
c'est aussi vrai euh pour la
mondialisation de la société de l'information qui nécessite
beaucoup de transports donc beaucoup de
pétrole etc donc euh
tout ce dont on a été témoin ces
deux derniers siècles est
dû à un processus fait t  l'augmentation de
l'approvisionnement en énergie donc le parc de
machines
maintenant on a deux facteurs limitants euh le
premier c'est qu'il faut
50 à 400 millions d'euros pour former ça
donc c'est pas renouvelable au fil
des temps historiques et les mathématiques racontent
ça quand on dessine  à partir d'une ressource non renouvelable
la courbe d'extraction ne peut que suivre la
forme d'un pic d'
accord c'est tout ce qu'elle peut faire c'est un
théorème mathématique je peux encore le
démontrer
et c'est vrai pour le pétrole mais c'est aussi vrai
pour le cuivre ou le
vanadium ou euh le minerai d'aluminium etc
les diamants désolé mesdames donc tout va
suivre la même courbe
avec un pic pour les ressources non renouvelables
et vous avez un deuxième facteur limitant
qui est le changement climatique
euh une grande différence entre les deux c'est
qu'en ce qui concerne le changement climatique toutes les
informations sont publiques car c'est
émis par des laboratoires de recherche et des
laboratoires de recherche comme vous le savez
par définition rendre public tout le nœud
ici toutes les informations sont détaillées par
intérêt privé
donc si vous voulez avoir  a je dirais
un avis dans lequel tu es confiant
sur ce qui se passe dans les énergies fossiles
il faut cinq à dix ans euh pour
discuter avec des experts partout
euh et espérer qu'ils auront un
peu trop bu et te dire la vérité
euh
c'est très  très long euh pour avoir une
image cohérente
de euh je dirais un avenir de combustibles fossiles
euh
de ce point de vue parce que l'
information est privée
et entre nous avons ceci donc le pib
est un flux
qui est créé en transformant les
ressources naturelles avec de l'énergie non renouvelable
donc une fois que vous avez compris que vous
comprenez euh la situation difficile
de l'équipe des prés euh donc
c'est de retour aux origines alors que je parle à des
gens qui viennent du même endroit
euh comme vous le savez peut-être comme vous le savez peut-être désolé
euh danella et dennis meadows et  d'autres
personnes
du mit euh il y a 50 ans ont
publié un rapport intitulé les limites de la
croissance
suite à la dynamique du système euh
qu'ils ont réalisée dans le laboratoire du
mit et disant que tant
que nous recherchons l'économie  croissance le système est
voué à s'effondrer
peu importe à quel point nous sommes optimistes
sur les hypothèses sur le stock initial de
ressources non renouvelables
ou le progrès technologique
c'est la situation difficile qui a été émise
concernant le pétrole par exemple euh le
je dirais que le pic est passé pour
le pétrole conventionnel  Il y a 12 ans,
euh, je suis sûr que vous n'êtes pas au courant de ce
rapport, euh, je suis sûr que peu d'entre vous
sont au courant de ce rapport publié par
l'agence internationale de l'énergie, mais
je le savais bien avant euh
en 2018, ils ont publié un  rapport disant que
le pétrole conventionnel, qui est tout ce qui n'est
pas du pétrole de schiste
et des sables bitumineux, a connu un pic en
et a diminué depuis
maintenant et je vais terminer avec cela,
comment pouvez-vous imaginer l'avenir euh dans
ce que
j'ai  a expliqué qu'il y a une petite règle de
trois que j'aime
appelée l'identité kaya qui est d'une
grande aide
pour comprendre où nous pourrions aller cela
commence par une tautologie
qui est que les émissions de co2 sont égales à
elles-mêmes
ce qui est jusqu'à présent j'espère yo  vous accepterez
maintenant sur la partie droite de cette identité que
je vais diviser et multiplier
par l'approvisionnement énergétique euh dans le monde
ici vous avez un terme qui est co2
sur l'énergie et le co2 sur l'énergie est essentiellement
la quantité de co2 que vous devez mettre  dans les airs
pour obtenir une unité de transformation du
monde parce que l'énergie est transformation
par définition dans le monde physique
donc c'est le débat pour savoir si on
doit remplacer le charbon par le nucléaire le
pétrole par le gaz etc
alors je vais diviser et multiplier par
le pib
c'est une unité qui est l'énergie par unité
de pib donc c'est combien vous devez
transformer le monde
pour obtenir une unité de valeur ajoutée euh pour
quelque chose qui est
plus utile que les ressources naturelles dont
il dérive
c'est beaucoup plus pratique de manger un  œuf
avec une fourchette ou avec une cuillère qu'avec
du minerai de fer
donc on aime bien transformer le minerai de fer en
cuillères car on trouve plus
pratique que la transformation demande de l'
énergie et apporte une valeur ajoutée
alors je vais multiplier et diviser par
le wo  rld population
et ici vous avez la quantité de services
par habitant,
donc la quantité de valeur ajoutée est un proxy
pour les services
cuillères forex tables chaises et
Internet
fois la population donc ce que je viens d'
écrire,
c'est que tout est égal sinon les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sont un
fonction linéaire de la taille de la population
donc plus on est nombreux plus on
admet
tout restant égal sinon c'est
proportionnel c'est la la courbe que
je viens de montrer avant
à la production par tête qui fait
bien sur le débat on peut  peut-on
avoir
un découplage absolu avec cette augmentation
alors que cela diminue
alors c'est l'intensité énergétique des
économies donc si nous pouvons utiliser moins d'énergie
pour produire la même chose cela s'améliore
et c'est un premier terme qui implique la
technologie
cela n'implique pas la technologie et cela
ne  n'implique pas la technologie
et puis vous avez le dernier terme ici
qui est la teneur en carbone de l'énergie
et je viens d'expliquer avant qu'il ne soit
remplacé  ng un froid par les énergies renouvelables appelées
nucléaire et cetera
maintenant si nous voulons nous en tenir aux deux
degrés,
nous devons diviser les émissions de co2 par trois
par deux mille cinquante
et rappelle que même si nous ne
voulons pas réduire les émissions de co2,
il viendra  un jour où l'
approvisionnement en combustibles fossiles diminuera à
cause de la limitation des combustibles
fossiles comme je l'ai dit, extraire d'un
stock non renouvelable
ne peut que passer par un pic et diminuer
par la suite
donc finalement cela diminuera de toute façon
cela diminuera de toute façon euh
et euh le le le  je dirais que la partie sympa
euh avec une identité c'est que si c'est
divisé par trois
quelque part ici je dois avoir une combinaison
qui permet d'avoir aussi une division par
trois
une première façon d'arriver à une solution est de
diviser la population par trois euh
ça  n'est pas quelque chose que les gens considèrent
avec beaucoup d'optimisme ou
plutôt avec beaucoup de
joie  o-tiers de leurs euh
parents et amis euh qui
disparaîtraient pour résoudre le problème
euh et euh quand on regarde les scénarios
qui sont émis par les démocrates qui disent
que la population
pourrait augmenter de 25 en 2015. maintenant c'est un
pourrait
parce que  si nous obtenons une crique supplémentaire en 2032
qui est aussi méchante que le cochon noir
que nous avions en Europe au moyen
âge, la
moitié de la population est tuée
et c'est tout,
je veux dire donc c'est un scénario ce n'est pas une
prévision d'
accord méfiez-vous de ne pas  mélanger des scénarios
avec des prévisions
un scénario n'est pas une prévision d'accord
c'est une hypothèse
si nous n'avons pas de plaidoyer majeur
c'est quelque chose qui va être
proche de ça d'
accord mais ce n'est pas une prédiction
donc euh cela devrait être divisé par trois
et cela  augmente de 1,25
donc évidemment les trois facteurs restants
devraient être divisés par 3,75 d'
accord c'est presque quatre
nous pourrions diviser la production par habitant
par quatre c'est une façon de résoudre l'
identité
signifie que les salaires de tout le monde sont
divisés  par quatre
ou r divisé par quatre plutôt euh signifie
que les pensions sont divisées par quatre
euh et cetera c'est une façon de résoudre le
problème
euh vous ne trouveriez pas un
seul économiste plaidant pour que
ce n'est pas vrai et que ce n'est pas
va arriver
juste qu'il ne veut pas croire euh
dans cette option et toutes les économies
vous disent que nous avons une croissance à long terme,
ce qui est la plus grosse blague que j'aie jamais
entendue
euh donc nous avons une croissance à long terme  et donc
le pib par habitant va augmenter
de deux pour cent par an
euh vous aurez remarqué que ces derniers temps ça
n'a pas été le cas mais
ça n'empêche pas ces gens de
croire que ça ne reprendra pas
euh les intérêts composés faites en sorte  que si
vous augmentez quelque chose de 2
par an pendant 30 ans, vous obtenez la
multiplication par presque 2.
donc si nous croyons en ce scénario
et si nous croyons que nous pouvons avoir de la
croissance,
c'est un chem et je ne devrais pas
euh alors euh ces deux  les termes
sont multipliés par disons deux
lorsque ce sho  uld être divisé par trois
cela signifie que les correctifs techniques devraient faire
le travail de diviser
la combinaison de ces deux termes par
six
nous sommes d'accord c'est une règle de trois très
simple
pouvons-nous diviser la densité énergétique de l'
économie par 6
en 30 ans par 6 en  30 ans et
bien, nous pouvons regarder le curriculum vitae
des personnes qui postuleraient pour
un tel emploi
et et et nous pouvons voir
que euh en fait, ce que cette personne pourrait
se vanter
est une diminution d'un peu plus de 10
au cours des deux dernières décennies d'accord,
donc nous  peut espérer quelque chose comme 30 de
moins dans les 30 années à venir
et parmi ces 12 pour cent désolé d'entrer
dans les détails
mais l'une des causes de ce gain
est l'inefficacité ce n'est pas le fait que nous
avions de
l'efficacité physique c'est le fait que
nous avions un
faux pib  venant de l'inflation des
actifs,
vous avez peut-être remarqué que le coût de
l'immobilier
euh que le coût des actions euh que le
coût du bitcoin
euh tout ce qui peut être échangé et le
coût de l'art
vient de monter en flèche euh depuis les
deux dernières décennies
et surtout pour la dernière décennie
grâce à l'assouplissement quantitatif
et cela crée un faux PIB qui n'est pas
actualisé
euh quand vous calculez le PIB pour de
vrai
donc une partie de cela est un faux
ce n'est pas vrai l'efficacité que vous aviez
dans la fabrication du ciment la fabrication de l'acier la
construction automobile  etc
donc cela ne va pas faire le travail tout
seul comme ça
et maintenant vous pouvez regarder la
teneur en carbone de l'énergie à cause du
balai renouvelable etc et donc ce que vous pouvez
voir,
c'est qu'au cours des deux dernières décennies
grâce au boom des énergies renouvelables  maintenant, en
fait, grâce à rien,
nous avons eu presque zéro au cours des deux dernières
décennies, en fait, la tendance à la
diminution lente a été plus rapide avant les
énergies renouvelables
qu'après, car la bombe nucléaire était beaucoup
plus efficace
et le passage du charbon au gaz dans une partie
de la production d'électricité était  aussi
plus efficace
donc ce que vous pouvez voir ici euh c'est en fait
la diminution majeure des émissions de co2
aux états-unis au cours des deux dernières
décennies  est dû à cela
au passage du charbon au gaz dans la production d'électricité
qui est la cause principale et cela n'a rien
à voir avec obama ou trump ou quoi que ce soit,
donc vous pouvez voir ici
qu'il est très peu probable que la combinaison
de ces
deux va  divisez ces deux termes en
six par six
quand nous avons une population en hausse et
un pib par habitant en hausse
ce que nous pourrions avoir si nous le voulions mais euh
vite sur vos ceintures de sécurité euh
nous devrions travailler sur une
augmentation plus lente une plus lente de la population donc
le  la première chose qui est très utile
si nous voulons atténuer le changement climatique
est de s'occuper de limiter autant que nous le
pouvons
avec bien sûr des méthodes pacifiques l'
augmentation de la population mondiale
les méthodes pacifiques sont par exemple l'
éducation des femmes et l'autonomisation
des femmes les systèmes sociaux euh des choses comme ça  ce
n'est pas
du tout des correctifs technologiques ce n'est pas du tout
un correctif technologique qui
va convaincre une femme
qu'il est souhaitable d'avoir moins d'enfants
pas non pas une seule minute euh
on pourrait accepter une diminution  du PIB une
lente diminution du PIB par habitant
aujourd'hui de toute façon nous sommes économiquement obèses
nous mangeons trop nous buvons trop nous
conduisons trop
nous avons deux voitures qui sont trop grosses
je veux dire donc ça ne va pas être
très douloureux en fait c'est  ça va être
plutôt utile
si on fait ça bien sûr euh si on veut
être communiste dans le monde pour qu'au
final
un indien ait le même pib par habitant
qu'un américain
c'est plutôt division par 46 45 etc aux
us
mais quand même  on peut retirer une
fraction importante du pib
et ça ne va pas vraiment gêner nos conditions de vie
ça va vraiment gêner notre statut social
ça va gêner un certain nombre de
choses mais pas vraiment une façon de vivre
quand on y pense
donc  le le défi ici est la
transition
plutôt que l'état final
et ce ne sera pas la technologie
ne sera d'aucune aide
euh c'est de la psychologie sociologie euh
souhaitable
etc ce n'est pas animal une question de
technologie c'est une question de technologie  ologie et si on
accélère
euh on peut on pourrait l'atteindre mais il
faut décider que c'est le premier objectif
de l'économie
le premier d'accord ne pas avoir euh d'entreprises
euh qui valent un milliard au
nasdaq d'accord c'est pas
un objectif qu'on devrait avoir  ceci en tant que
premier objectif de l'économie,
nous pouvons probablement atteindre un à un pour
un pour 1,5% par an
euh dans euh moteurs, etc.
et si nous sommes vraiment disposés,
nous pourrions atteindre quelque chose comme deux
pour cent par an,
ce qui signifie par exemple que chaque année
dans  le monde on remplace 80 centrales à charbon
par des centrales nucléaires d'accord
euh euh aux états unis tu as un peu
moins de 100 réacteurs nucléaires donc ça
te donne une idée un ordre de
grandeur donc en gros tu devrais
dupliquer le parc nucléaire
des états unis chaque année  d'accord
si nous faisons tout cela alors nous relevons le
défi
donc c'est la fin ou en fait la fin
pas la fin comme dans la chanson de jim morrison
mais c'est la fin de mon discours
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez découvert un couple
peu  e choses au
cours de cette conférence concernant l'ampleur
du défi
et ce défi, nous pouvons le relever
ou nous pouvons simplement soumettre la conséquence
je dirais euh euh souffre à cause des
conséquences
euh c'est une statue de confucius
tu connais un ancien chinois
je ne '  je connais les philosophies
et parmi les choses qu'il a dit euh il a
dit qu'on peut devenir sage
euh de trois manières la première
est de penser euh quelle est la meilleure
donc j'espère que vous accepterez de penser
la seconde est de suivre ceux qui  avoir des
pensées
qui sont de l'imitation mais ensuite vous devez faire
confiance aux gens
sans vouloir ou faire semblant de
comprendre
et la façon la plus difficile d'apprendre
est par l'expérience qui est un
essai et voir euh
et voir où cela vous mène mais
quand vous êtes dans une course contre le  l'horloge
c'est la meilleure option pour échouer, donc mon
conseil
est de penser d'abord et d'encourager tout le monde à
penser d'abord
quelle est la chose que nous ennuyons de ne pas
faire aujourd'hui,
ils pensent que nous ne faisons pas aujourd'hui
et la deuxième chose qu'il a dite est
a dit que euh
aujourd'hui euh fondamentalement euh
nous faisons l'inverse de ce qu'il a conseillé
nous ajustons les étapes d'action pour
désolé nous ajustons l'objectif aux
étapes d'action
ce serait trop difficile d'agir alors n'agissons pas
mais comme je l'ai expliqué avant de ne pas agir
ne va pas empêcher de souffrir
ça garantit juste
la chose le fait que juste un
peu plus tard au
lieu de résoudre le problème le problème
nous résoudra
d'une certaine manière d'accord euh
la solution s'effondrera
malheureusement parce que nous vivons sur le
phénix  l'usine a
peut-être été un peu longue mais
je suis ouvert aux questions
s'il y a une question
merci merci beaucoup pour votre
présentation qui était euh
très perspicace et oui très complète
tous ceux qui veulent rester en ce moment
pouvons-nous y aller un peu  euh
plus que le temps que nous avons décidé à l'
origine euh cependant nous allons
poser et répondre à quelques questions ici en ce
moment
euh quand vous quand nous regardons le q
a nous pouvons voir
plusieurs questions sur la géoingénierie
et aussi un ca  technologies d'élimination du rbon
donc jean-marc jean-covici qu'auriez-
vous à dire
en quelques mots sur les technologies d'élimination du carbone
et
aussi les technologies d'élimination du carbone de la géo-ingénierie solaire
euh en gros vous avez quelque chose qui est
très efficace et très ancien qui
s'appelle des arbres
donc le  la meilleure technologie d'élimination du carbone
que nous ayons est de faire pousser des forêts
euh si nous voulons faire pousser des forêts nous devons
récupérer des terres
qui étaient initialement consacrées aux cultures
donc fondamentalement si nous voulons faire pousser des forêts
nous devons manger moins de viande en france et
aux états-unis c'est le  même chose,
quatre-vingts pour cent des surfaces
consacrées à l'agriculture, à la
fois aux pâturages et aux cultures, servent à nourrir les
animaux,
donc si nous voulons couper pour capturer le carbone
de l'atmosphère,
la meilleure chose que nous puissions faire est de manger
moins de viande,
une autre chose que nous pouvons faire est de  avoir
des techniques agricoles
euh comme pas de labour euh arrêter de labourer etc
euh qui sont efficaces
pour remettre dans le sol une partie
du carbone qui a été retiré du
sol
lorsque nous transformons les forêts en sol agricole
que le deuxième puits que nous forestons c'est
la meilleure option les
gens qui rêvent de solutions technologiques
pour éliminer le dioxyde de carbone de l'air
rêvent de faire ce qui suit le rêve
d'éliminer
une molécule inerte
parce que comme je l'ai dit avant le dioxyde de carbone
est une
molécule interne, c'est pourquoi elle n'a
aucun processus chimique qui l'enlève
de l'air
le rêve d'enlever une molécule inerte
de l'air et cette molécule inerte
est présente à une concentration de 0,04
maintenant n'importe lequel d'entre vous qui a fait de la physique
ou la chimie sait que l'élimination d'une
molécule inerte présente à la
concentration
de 0,04% va vous coûter
une dépense énergétique massive et en fait, les
gens qui ont fait un calcul de premier ordre
ont eu les résultats que je n'ai pas
vérifié
mais je  faites-lui confiance que cela va coûter
environ la moitié de l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial pour
faire cela
[Rires]
oui vous savez euh quelque chose qui
est euh l'outil le plus puissant  à je sais
quand vous voulez évaluer une idée c'est une
règle de trois
c'est l'outil le plus puissant et ce que
j'appelle ce que je dis à mes étudiants
c'est que lorsqu'un bon calcul de premier ordre
vous amène à un résultat très différent
d'un calcul sophistiqué  modèle
la seule question est de savoir où le modèle
n'a pas réussi à représenter la réalité
mais c'est la seule question pertinente
quelque part où il a échoué
euh bien sûr vous devez avoir un
calcul de premier ordre pertinent mais
euh euh joe engineering
est le rêve de modifier
le bilan énergétique de  le
climat de la terre par exemple
euh ancien prix nobel de chimie paul
cretin a
pensé à mettre du dioxyde de soufre dans la
haute
atmosphère afin de créer des sulfates qui
refléteront les rayons du soleil
ma conviction est que c'est quelque chose
qui est probablement
plus dangereux qu'une bonne idée pour la
suite  raisons
la première c'est que euh
toi tu n'as pas le temps de euh être
sûr
que tu vas réussir quand tu
fais ça c'est un pari
on est sûr de réussir  si on remplace
les centrales à charbon par des réacteurs nucléaires
on est sûr de réussir c'est prouvé on
sait faire
ok t'es pas sûr du tout de réussir
euh si tu mets du dioxyde de soufre dans la
haute atmosphère parce que
ça peut arriver de ce côté là  du
dioxyde de soufre
va y rester pendant une période plus courte
que ce à quoi vous vous attendiez
et si vous mettez des quantités massives de soufre
dans l'atmosphère, vous obtiendrez des
quantités massives de pluies acides,
donc pour empêcher les écosystèmes,
vous allez les tuer
avec  euh les pluies acides qui sont une très bonne
idée
et cetera donc et la dernière chose est que
ces correctifs vous devez les maintenir
tout le temps et euh les simulations ont
montré
que le jour où vous arrêtez non seulement
le système climatique rattrape le
réchauffement que vous  aurait évité dans
quelques années,
mais cela ajoute au réchauffement
qui se serait produit avec les émissions supplémentaires de
gaz à effet de serre,
donc essentiellement le jour où vous avez arrêté de mettre
du dioxyde de soufre dans la haute atmosphère
parce que  vous
êtes à court de ballons, de fusées à soufre
ou de quoi que ce soit d'autre
, euh, alors
la température moyenne sur terre
monte en flèche de quelques degrés en
quelques années
, puis vous tuez une fraction importante
de l'humanité, euh l'autre rêve qui
serait de mettre  des miroirs
euh au point de lagrange euh entre la
terre
et le soleil c'est aussi quelque chose que quand
on regarde les ordres de grandeur
c'est comme si mr moss croyait qu'il
va mettre 1 milliard de personnes sur mars je veux dire
peut-être qu'il va  se
mettre sur mars s'il a beaucoup de chance et
qu'il va s'ennuyer beaucoup euh parce
qu'il ne peut même pas sortir se balader
euh mais euh si tu veux vraiment que certains
veulent finir euh comme dans 2001 l'
odyssée de l'espace c'est son problème
euh mais tu ne l'es pas  va déplacer un
milliard de personnes donc
ce sont des rêves je veux dire qu'il y a de beaux
rêves peut-être
mais euh nous devrions être pragmatiques et euh
être pragmatique
euh nécessite de faire signe ou ou de se débarrasser
des idées où un simple calcul  ation un
simple calcul de premier ordre montre
que ça ne marchera jamais
je vois que je dis merci et euh quand tu
dis que c'est un rêve
euh tu veux probablement aussi dire à cause du
manque d'énergie que nous allons
rencontrer à un moment donné dans le futur oui
bien sûr oui
donc par rapport à ça j'ai une question
euh pour résumer toutes les questions que je peux
lire
c'est euh en tant que chercheur et en tant que
chercheur dans par exemple dans dans le
monde numérique
ou dans euh pour l'informatique etc
comment on fait et aussi en tant que citoyens  euh
comment on s'adapte à ça comment on adapte
notre recherche comment on adapte nos
universités
pour faire face au manque d'énergie comment faire
face euh faire face ouais le manque d'
argent qui vient avec le manque d'énergie
et en même temps euh produire  euh
la recherche pour réduire les
émissions et s'adapter à ce monde
est là
je sais qu'il n'y a pas de réponse mais pourriez-vous
donner peut-être une piste
sur ce euh je vais répondre à une
question majeure avant
oui ma photo de fond euh est dans le
nord  une partie
de la bretagne
[Rires]
c  perdre au café pour ceux d'entre vous qui
connaissent l'
endroit comment on s'adapte
on s'adapte en décidant qu'on travaille sur le
sujet
euh ça ne va pas être facile et ça
ne va pas être instantané
euh comme toi comme tu l'as dit euh
quand tu  lisez ma courte biographie
je suis impliqué dans ce problème
euh depuis 20 ans
donc bien sûr j'ai commencé à être à l'aise
avec le problème quels sont les
je dirais des choses sur lesquelles nous devrions vraiment
travailler
euh et des impasses euh  qu'il ne faut pas
regarder ou
euh enlever très très vite ça
va prendre ton temps
euh c'est le truc qu'on n'a pas
mais quand même ça va prendre ton temps
euh pour regarder en profondeur le problème
et voir comment  vous pouvez le combiner
avec le monde dans lequel vous vivez aujourd'hui
et il n'y a pas d'autre moyen
c'est un problème complexe cela a été dit
au début
nous vivons dans un monde complexe euh cela a aussi
été dit au début l'
énergie a encadré tout ce qui
nous entoure je  'ai dit qu'il a
essayé de l'expliquer euh donc euh tu ne
vas pas admettre
ce web complexe euh en quelques minutes
même en quelques heures
même en quelques jours et même en
quelques années
euh donc la première chose utile que vous
pouvez faire est de diffuser les connaissances autour de
euh la deuxième chose utile à faire
est de euh affronter  ce qui vous entoure
à cette comptabilité spéciale qui est
la comptabilité carbone
qui vous donne une première vue sur où
agir
euh et nous devons apprendre la grammaire nous
devons apprendre les chiffres qui sont
associés à cette question
qui comme je l'ai dit euh l'énergie et le
climat  le défi du changement n'est nulle part
dans les économies conventionnelles, donc en ce qui concerne
l'unité
que vous manipulez toute la journée, c'est-à-dire l'
argent,
vous êtes aveugle par rapport à ce que je viens d'
expliquer,
vous êtes aveugle parce qu'il a été
conçu, donc je veux dire que ce n'est pas parce que
je suis moi  je ne suis pas prétentieux en disant
que c'est juste
qu'il a été conçu donc
euh donc la voie à suivre c'est un long
voyage pour aborder ce problème
euh c'est un très long voyage et euh tout ce
que j'espère
euh c'est qu'un certain nombre de  le pe  Les personnes qui
ont écouté maintenant souhaitent
euh commencer ce voyage euh mais
c'est comme se débarrasser
du moteur et ça va être aussi
difficile
[Rires]
[Musique]
je vois euh bien merci euh d'avoir répondu à
ces deux questions
euh oh je vois  une autre question
euh ouais quelqu'un demande une bonne source
pour
étudier le kaya l'identité du kaya
il y a une page sur mon
site perso donc mon site perso porte mon
nom euh
jean vc.com euh et il y a une
page qui s'appelle euh c'est quoi le  kaya
et vous pouvez vous référer à cette page euh c'est un
peu vieux parce que la plupart de ce
site a été écrit quand j'avais le temps,
ce qui est maintenant quelque chose qui me
manque cruellement euh
mais euh je veux dire que la physique est éternelle donc
même si c'est toute la partie de  c'est encore
c'est toujours valable
euh et tu verras euh tu peux revenir
sur cette identité pas à pas
euh c'est aussi ils sont ils sont
ça alors quand il faut
[Musique]
si tu veux approfondir euh
les différents termes
euh  ça fait partie du voyage que je  'ai
juste mentionné avant
euh il faut regarder les
scénarios démographiques et regarder ce qui peut les
changer euh regarder euh
dans quelle mesure euh les gens seraient
mécontents
euh de la taille de leurs voitures euh
diminué un peu etc
euh donc tout ça fait partie  de l'
enquête que vous devez faire
euh ce n'est pas sur ma page Web bien sûr euh
mais je peux dire que
ma page Web peut être utilisée comme une sorte de
rappel
pour savoir où chercher oh merci pour
la réponse euh il y a une
question aussi sur  les crypto-monnaies, donc je
suppose que cela est
très directement lié à la
numérisation
de l'économie comme nous le disons euh voudriez-
vous avoir un mot sur euh
les expériences cryptographiques et euh les visualisations
oui je vais avoir un mot avant
sur l'économie numérique dans son ensemble  euh
au projet de navire euh et euh le au
moins le résumé pour les décideurs politiques est
disponible en anglais
euh nous avons publié il y a un an et demi ou
deux ans notre rapport sur l'
empreinte carbone du système iit
de l'économie numérique tod  ay si
tu résumes
la fabrication de tout l'appareil que l'
on utilise des
ordinateurs comme celui que j'utilise en
ce moment smartphones
serveurs réseaux euh parce qu'il faut des
composants
euh pour le réseau donc écran
tv écrans tv connectés
donc la fabrication de tout ça  et vous
ajoutez en plus
la production d'électricité pour faire fonctionner tout
ça et euh
la production d'électricité sur terre je l'ai
déjà montré
c'est plus de 25 de vos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
vous arrivez au résultat qu'en 2018
le numérique était responsable de 4
%
de  le réseau a des émissions de gaz sur
terre
qui équivaut à la flotte mondiale
de camions
et ça augmente de huit à dix
pour cent par an
huit à dix pour cent par an il n'y a
rien de moins durable que
l'économie numérique
et en 2025 à ce rythme
c'est  va être l'équivalent de la
flotte mondiale de voitures
bien flotte de voitures 80 du flux de données
sur le réseau est vidéo donc
ce que nous faisons en ce moment en fait
quand vous loo  k
à la répartition de ces 80%, un
quart de ces 80%
est netflix et similaire
parce que c'est point à point et c'est
beaucoup plus exigeant
en ressources qu'un de trop
que nous avions auparavant avec euh tv analogique
25 est euh sites porno
25 est youtube
et 25 pourcent euh c'est tout le reste d'
images euh animées comme la vidéo qu'on utilise en
ce moment euh toute la vidéo de ton
petit cousin qui vient d'avoir ses premières
dents
euh et que bien sûr la mère doit
écarter ou le père la maman fière  ou
père doit s'étaler environ euh trois
secondes et demie
juste juste après euh donc ça fait 80
% du flux de données euh sur internet donc l'augmentation
de euh l'empreinte carbone
de l'économie numérique est essentiellement
liée
à l'augmentation de la consommation de
encore des vidéos c'est essentiel à notre
bonheur c'est essentiel à notre bonheur de voir
euh d'avoir un peu meilleure définition
pour regarder le sexe je ne suis pas
sûr c'est essentiel à notre bonheur d'avoir
une meilleure définition  à regarder ton
petit cousin faire
ses premières dents alors mais on creuse
partout
extraire des métaux et mettre plein de
co2 dans l'atmosphère pour profiter de
ce genre de chose
euh les crypto-monnaies en font partie
une petite partie aujourd'hui mais ça risque d'augmenter
de  ce système numérique
fondamentalement, ils ne servent à rien,
fondamentalement, ils ne servent à rien, je veux dire
le bénéfice que nous obtenons des
crypto-monnaies
euh qui permettent de payer une rançon euh quand
vous obtenez
quand vous êtes victime de chantage euh ou je veux dire
quel est l'avantage non  aucun avantage
euh donc c'est parmi les choses auxquelles nous
devrions renoncer instantanément euh
si nous étions un peu sages
c'est probablement une partie aussi peut-être de
la croissance artificielle du pib la
croissance du pib bien sûr
probablement bien merci je pense que maintenant
nous y sommes allés
pendant deux heures donc euh pour clore
cette conférence je voudrais remercier
tout le monde
d'être venu ici merci caroline de
m'avoir aidé à organiser ça
merci jean-marc d'être venu le dernier mais
pas des moindres
jean-marc y serait  ous avez un mot pour les
étudiants chercheurs du mit car
je ne sais pas pour améliorer leurs
recherches
vers une meilleure compréhension du
changement climatique, etc.
probablement l'un des défis les plus
difficiles que nous
devons relever, je veux dire trouver un moyen de
vivre une histoire paisible et paisible
pendant les 80 années à venir sur la planète surpeuplée
est probablement l'un des défis les plus
difficiles dont vous puissiez rêver
, nous avons donc désespérément besoin  tous les cerveaux
que nous pouvons trouver euh pour être
impliqués
dans euh trouver une partie de la solution
euh à ce problème
je ne vais pas vous donner des solutions miracles
et dire euh bien sûr voici une liste de
thèmes que vous devriez
euh  sais que je veux dire que vous êtes des gens intelligents
sinon vous n'auriez pas
vous ne feriez pas euh un doctorat au
mit
donc vous trouverez par vous-mêmes euh encore mon
mon mon conseil est d'abord d'apprendre
euh comprendre correctement euh th  e problème
tu as eu 1 an une heure et
demie d'histoire c'est pas assez euh
20 heures c'est quelque chose qui se rapproche de
ce dont tu as besoin
et puis trouve par toi même euh ce que tu
pourrais
regarder pour faire un peu partie de la
solution
merci  merci beaucoup donc je pense
euh caroline je vais te laisser
le dernier mot ouais merveilleux euh
encore merci beaucoup de nous avoir rejoint
sean mark qui était très
stimulant avec un peu d'
humour mais aussi très dégrisant
euh et tu sais  introduit de nouvelles façons
de penser aux choses, ce qui
est très intéressant et merci à
tous ceux qui sont restés avec nous, je sais que nous
avons dépassé un peu le temps, mais je suis content d'avoir eu la
chance de
répondre à certaines des questions et d'avoir un
peu de  dialogue
euh et juste pour je suppose une question logistique
sean mark euh serons-nous en mesure de partager
vos diapositives avec toute personne intéressée
espace et euh  je vous enverrai les diapositives
après avoir corrigé la petite erreur
que j'ai mentionnée lors de la conférence
fantastique bien merci encore à
tous merci jean-marc
et j'espère que tout le monde passe une bonne fin
de journée d'
accord merci beaucoup  bon
reste de ta vie parce que je ne suis pas sûr de
te parler au
revoir au revoir